[Music]
hey everybody what's going on so as you
can tell behind me this is the all new
24 inch imac m1 edition
the brand new one in orange or i'm going
to call it coral nonetheless we'll talk
about all that in just a bit but here
are some things
you need to know about the imac before
picking one up check them out
[Music]
all right guys before we kick things off
i do want to let you know i'm not paid
her sponsor for this review these are my
thoughts and my thoughts only and i'm
not going to go through all the specs
because if you want to know the specs
apple's got a beautiful website okay i'm
going to talk to you guys about what
it's like to use and some of the points
i think are more
valuable for you if you're going to pick
up one of these and things that you
should know about all right so first off
i want to talk about the packaging on
this
just to cut things short this is the
most beautiful packaging i've seen on
any computer to date it cuts color
coordinating to the imac it's beautiful
it's recyclables it's just all that
sustainability it's all in there but it
is
awesome to see and it just gives you
that whole experience when you first
unbox the imac like you just have this
big smile on your face at least for me
that's what it was like the colors as
good as they are on the website
they're even better in person case in
point i got the orange variant here now
orange would not be my first choice in
getting an imac but when i open up the
box
and i saw it's like a deep coral color
and it's just got these it's
multi-dimensional in terms of the back
the stand area this peach color here the
white frame around the display
it just all
works and it's beautiful even the track
pad the keyboard the mouse it's all
color coordinating even the cable is
color coordinated so
it's this whole thing that it's going to
be hard for you guys to choose and i
would recommend
going to the apple store first if you
can do so if there's one near you to see
all the colors and then decide because
you might be surprised you might go for
a color that you weren't necessarily
going to go for in the beginning because
they just look so different in person
and they actually look better in my
personal opinion
the next things we're going to talk
about is just how beautiful this thing
is i mean apple makes great looking
products we know this but this is
stunning it's really thin
um it's compact in its size and it's
really lightweight honestly you can pick
this up and you can move it around with
you i'm not going to travel with it some
people do
but you can it's actually very
lightweight you got four ports on the
back of it you've got two usbc 3 ports
you've got two thunderbolt 3 usb 4 ports
on this so you are
you're pretty much good to go you might
want to get a dock if you want to get it
it's in the back so it's a little bit
hard to see in the beginning um i
personally would recommend getting a
dock but they're there for you got to of
course you got a headphone jack there
you can plug in your speakers if you
want to do that so the auxiliary input
you're good to go but it's so thin
and it's just beautiful so you got a
1080p hd webcam on this now which is
great because a lot of people we were
complaining why is apple putting on
these like 720 low res webcams
we're working from home now we we need
high resolution and the front facing
camera on the iphones are fantastic and
that's small they could put in this and
they did so hats off to apple for that
it makes a big difference in terms of
your you know you're doing your web
conferencing and chatting with that it's
fantastic the display on this 4.5 k
retina display it's beautiful colors are
great it's bright enough you're gonna
have no issues with this at all as a
matter of fact you might even want a
larger display you go why did apple and
give us 24 inches now 24 is great for
most of us out there but i've been
spoiled with larger sized displays and
yeah i would i would take a larger imac
if they made one maybe they will in the
future who knows but this is a beautiful
display but besides that i mean
everything as i mentioned color
coordinated it's all wireless except for
the mag safe cord in the back of it it's
just a very simple setup but it's
it's one of those things that i think
that if you want something that's
minimalist for your home or your office
or your your studio
and you don't want to fuss with a lot of
cables and you want to look really good
and maybe you have maybe your
configuration set up that you're going
to see the back of your computer as well
as the front
you're going to really love these imacs
they really are that good
so now let's talk about configuration on
this thing because this is where it's
going to be a little bit challenging for
a lot of you out there to figure out
like do i go 7 core 8 core 8 gigabytes
of ram 16 gigabytes of ram
you know how much storage do i go for so
let's chat about that right now now the
first thing you got to know about the m1
chip is that it's got unified ram inside
of it so it's configured differently
than pc laptops and desktops so when
people mention eight gigabytes of ram
normally pc people would be like oh
that's i mean how can i run anything off
eight gigabytes of ram but because it's
unified ram and what i mean by unified
ram is that the ram is on the same
chipset as the is the m1 chip so it's
sort of like the pathway for them to to
talk to each other and to share
information is much shorter
so
you don't need that much in terms of
numbers versus
let's say you know dedicated ram that's
outside of the chipset that you would
get on a pc for that matter so 8
gigabytes performs like a 16 gigabyte
ram configuration and 16 gigabytes
performs closer to 32 gigabytes you know
what i'm talking about if you were to
compare pc to apple with this m1 chip
this is a very efficient setup within
apple's m1 chipset so
for a lot of you out there the 8
gigabyte version is going to be more
than plenty and even 7 core versus 8
core you're not going to notice that
much of a difference if you're just
browsing the web or doing word documents
or doing basic school work or watching
videos i mean save your money get the
basic imac and then
spin a little extra if you want external
storage or if you want to get you know
another desk for that matter or another
setup say put your money towards that
versus trying to max it out now the only
reason i would say to max out this imac
in terms of eight core and 16 gigabytes
of ram if you're doing final cut pro
editing you know premiere pro heavy
photoshop autocad all that stuff that's
going to really push the system
then i
would go eight core 16 gigabytes of ram
and then of course i would up my storage
because the one thing you need to know
about the imacs unlike the older ones is
that you cannot
change your ram or change your storage
once you get it from apple it's built in
it's on the board and that is it
so
you really got to take in consideration
how you're going to use the imac today
and how you're going to use it in a
couple years from now but um so on my
variant i've got 512 gigabytes and for
me because i do a lot of photo editing
with medium format i'm using shooting
around 100 megapixels so my images are
around 200 megabytes raw
600 megabytes in a tiff file format and
i'm also editing in 4k 6k 8k
512 is not going to last me so
i
personally would opt for maybe one
terabyte and then get an ssd drive
or if i have the means i would go two
terabytes and then get an ssd drive now
people will say save your money get the
ssd drive don't worry about it but
you know
here's the thing that i've realized yes
these thunderbolt ssd drives are very
fast
but it's not the same as one that's
built in onto the uh the board right
it's never as it can be almost there but
never as fast so now that brings us into
performance now to give you the cliff
notes version of the performance of this
imac if you've used a 13-inch macbook
pro m1 variant the performance is
relatively the same
it's fast it's efficient
i've never heard the fans kick on it
runs final cut with ease photoshop with
ease lightroom is getting better
you know adobe hasn't updated all their
applications for the m1 chip as of yet i
think premiere pro is still outstanding
so i mean personally i would just move
over to final cut pro your life will be
a lot easier trust me your rendering
times like i mentioned before my
previous macbook pro review that i did
is that i had about an eight gigabyte
file was all 4k that i shot for a review
edit it myself and i rendered it out
into 4k and my rendering time was around
15 to 20 minutes
for an eight gigabyte file
now on premiere
i would have to go out for dinner have
some drinks come back and maybe it would
be done
on final cut it's very efficient and the
fans weren't even kicking on
that's how good the m1 chipset is
photoshop is fantastic with it as well
lightroom is also good you also have it
running this
virtual world with rosetta 2 so if you
have programs that are not designed for
the m1 chip they still run relatively
well case in point i use capture one
capture one is updating their software
very soon for the m1 and chip and it
runs
pretty good on this chipset i have to be
honest with you it's a little slow at
times but i'm also using pretty high
you know high resolution files so that
could be also an issue but my day-to-day
usage is no issues at all with capture
one and you'll find this a lot with a
lot of other software out there that the
rosetta 2 does a phenomenal job in terms
of you know transcoding that software to
work on the m1 chipset and and you don't
even notice that it's working it just
works which is great and also in terms
of gaming so if you don't want to if
you're not into intensive games out
there if you're using apple arcade or if
you want to play a little bit of
fortnite
no issues at all should be fine now if
you want to if you're an intensive gamer
then i think you might want to look
elsewhere for the time being unless the
rumored m1x chip or whatever you're
gonna call it comes out and maybe
they'll have a different graphics card
configuration with that and maybe
that'll just blow everybody's doors off
but until that happens
casual gaming yes
productivity yes
video editing yes you can do 8k on this
no issues at all multiple 4k tracks no
issues at all it works well especially
in final cut pro and your day-to-day
tasks
it's it's any it works with these
now a couple things that i wish were a
little bit different on it case in point
i'm not a big fan of the white bezels
i'm just not i prefer a black bezel
because it gives you that sense that the
screen is larger white makes things
smaller
i know there's companies like dbrand out
there that do make a skin that you can
cover the white
um also the ports are on the back of
this here and while that's great in
terms of you know keeping things hidden
you know from you know keeping your
desktop looking clean apple doesn't make
a hub so you have to buy an external hub
that means you're going to plug
something here or you have to use their
dongles which they made that go into the
ipad you'll have to use it for the back
of the imac case in point for the sd
cards there's no sd card slot on this so
you need a dongle and it's a little bit
flip it kind of flimsy how it hangs
there and just sort of neither here nor
there so i wish apple would have uh come
out with a hub maybe they will in the
future who knows color coordinated hub
that would be ideal but that's something
to take note of there's no numeric pad
on this keyboard here some people like
that some people don't it doesn't really
bother me but it is something to point
out
and
that's pretty much it um
i mean overall the imac is not meant to
be
the professional pro computer in apple's
lineup this is meant for day-to-day
usage yes some you can do some
productivity yes you can you can push it
a bit more than you probably would
normally push an imac in you know
previous years
but this is something that is just much
more it's aesthetically pleasing it's
great to have in the house it's gonna
look great in your office your studio
even in your kitchen
and it's just a beautiful machine it's
fun it's fun zacky that is the word this
computer is fun but anyway those are my
thoughts on the all-new imac let me know
your thoughts in the comments section
below any questions you have on it let
me know and i'll try to answer that for
you with that though stay safe take care
follow us on facebook subscribe to us on
youtube like this video helps out the
channel a lot we'll chat to you soon
take care
[Music]